well it is veterans day today we say
thank you to america's veterans
it's different this year though of
course because of the pandemic however
in boulder city they still managed to
hold
a new kind of parade hector mejia is in
boulder city
reporting on today's events hector good
afternoon
well good afternoon and even though the
pandemic changed the way
veterans day was observed out here today
it did not diminish at all the spirit of
patriotism we see in boulder city here
every single year this was a much
smaller ceremony
because of the virus we sort of took a
trip down
memory lane earlier with a parade of
beautiful
classic cars outside the nevada the
southern nevada state veterans home
roughly 150 veterans and their spouses
live here
the facility is owned and operated by
the state
we also saw local and state law
enforcement officers sending their
salutes
on a day we all express our gratitude
for the millions of men and women
who carried the burden to protect our
freedom we heard fascinating stories
from the heroes we met out here this
morning
veteran of the air force my whole family
is air force we're literally living
history
well i guess you could say that i was
there on the berlin wall come down
i was there when i went up it's nice
that we're all honored when you
the people come out here in boulder city
i don't have any living relatives now
everybody's
gone my brothers and sisters and stuff
and i'm doing all right
everybody treats me very nice here
veterans were also treated to a
spectacular flyover with the boulder
city veterans pilot group
flying five small planes all in
formation
a couple of times after the parade so
we'll go ahead and say it again
very genuinely thank you for your
service reporting live from boulder city
hector mejia
8 news now